The joe rogan experience try by day Joe Rogan podcast.
Bill Burr.
Impression.
That's pretty solid right there.
It's like a fucking baby bed.
Um,
so path from Menarche unleashes what can only be described as a cartoonish
hurling.
Like did you ever see that movie?
Oh my God,
it's the movie stand by me.
And the way that you never see in the real world.
Well this tops that I,
how could I packed up?
You just sit there.
Well he just did.
He's an animal that got this.
The guy that got puked on his,
he's still alive.
His open mouth.
Okay.
And it's
quite fine
while the than the beginning.
There's no visual for the first five minutes or you can cool.
There
is that helps you a joke.
Yeah.
Anybody would say no to her shoulder rubbing her.
Nashville
particularly shifts for this.
Flip her off.
This interview ends with my wife under the table.
Oh,
that's considered a failure.
I'd rather it not happen.
It's going to stay friends here.
I've been marked already today.
So markets,
Marvin,
you know a lot about that.
And what was your first experience that was unethical for you?
It's like what substance?
Well,
the first,
um,
the first experience I had with anything outside of the norm was Mbma.
That was the first like,
Whoa,
I didn't know this was available.
You know,
that was her first like introduction to the idea of consciousness altering
experiences and then the next one was suicide.
And then they first ineffable experience where you realized,
Oh,
I am connected directly to the device.
So sign.
But pretty much the,
um,
the MDA experience was just a realization how insecure I was and how insecure in
general are in our interactions with each other.
How much of our interactions with each other are sort of dependent upon our
perceptions about people are gonna react to us and we have this wall.
And that wall completely went away on MDM.
And I found that fascinating,
you know,
and I didn't know that that state was available,
but then the psilocybin experience was one where I just sort of kind of
understood that that was the first time I'd ever really wrapped my head around
the fact that this is not the top of the ground and you're not standing on
something and there's not an above you,
but that you're sort of in the middle of everything.
I have never really had it in my,
my own head before.
That was the first time where I just sort of really dawned on me and I have
watched cosmos documentaries.
I had seen a bunch of different,
you know,
things on astronomy where I sort of kind of got the idea that we're at the
outside edge of the galaxy and this galaxy swimming in these galaxies.
But it never really sunk in until the one mushroom trip where I'm like,
well,
you know,
you should really sort of wrap your head around like that.
It goes that way forever.
It and that way forever.
And the,
you know,
it's a weird,
it's turtles all the way down.
The DMT one was,
I always described Dmt as mushrooms,
times a million plus aliens,
you know.
So
have you had much experience with Iowasca?
No,
no,
no.
It's all been
my business partner.
The guy who makes the onyx stuff,
he's gone twice down to Peru now for seven,
seven.
He was seven days of the time between three and four experiences.
It was seven days.
You've gone to Machu Picchu and too many times.
Amazing.
Have you been there?
Oh,
you've got to see up.
Ever been.
It's really crazy.
It's teaching
ancient ruins that I've ever been to.
Well,
you're ahead of me there.
I,
for some reason I never been to the Miami really,
but I've been to the Inca ruins like probably six or seven times just because I
go down there so much.
I do a lot of stuff down,
you know,
uh,
both research and teaching and all that.
So what is your take on,
you know,
what's it called?
EO Tombow or up to Tom.
Oh,
Lantech,
Tom,
about all that.
That's that the incredibly large rocks.
And fit it in the unusual like jigsaw puzzles spaces.
They do that.
That's a good question.
What's your town?
Yeah,
man.
Well,
you know,
I don't really know my,
my opinion of,
I mean the other place you see that is sex,
a line item,
which is the ruins complex outside Cusco.
Similar thing,
you know,
rocks half the size of this room that had been moved around.
I don't know how to take to it,
but I will tell you one thing.
A EMS bell,
Graham Hancock's work,
well,
his,
we've had him on the podcast,
k he,
his writing so completely changed my perspective on that whole thing because I
think he's right.
I think that the ink is,
could not possibly have built,
I mean all of this in a hundred years,
you know,
the,
the height of the Inca empire was basically from 1450 to 1515 and they say
before that there wasn't much,
you know,
but I don't buy it.
And he says,
his postulate is that the Incas didn't create all this money metal architecture.
They sort of moved in that this came from a much more ancient civilization.
Possibly us back as far back as 15,000 years.
You know,
not all of the ruins,
but some of them like,
uh,
the,
the sun gates at Lake Titicaca too,
when not go and talks about how if you look at it,
it's astronomical orientations and all that.
It's aligned with the,
with the,
uh,
equal nautical points,
you know,
as they were 15,000 years ago.
I think his,
I think fingerprints of the gods,
which I'm only about halfway through.
It's just a fascinating book.
You read it,
it just throws the whole picture of archeology and to,
you know,
into question of you.
He's not a crazy remedied person.
He's presenting evidence like these maps giving talks about in the first
chapter.
This is not stuff that he's dreamed on.
We'll also the geological evidence on the spanx.
That's another one I'll see a lodging company brings up the,
uh,
the more recent studies have shown that there's a layer about at about 12,000
years where they repeatedly fine this glass that exists from nuclear explosions
when they blow up nuclear bombs or from asteroidal impacts.
Right.
I think that a 12,000 years ago we were probably hit by a devastating meteor
shower.
Yeah.
They found that in the same level all across the world.
They found this.
So it was like a global catastrophe and about 12,000 years.
And that's confirmed.
They have,
they've been finding this over and over and over again.
I mean,
it only stands to reason that if we do have all these ancient tales of
catastrophic events and civilizations wiped out,
that there must have been something and most likely we are,
you know,
uh,
we build and we fall in building astronomical events or global volcanic
eruptions that that changed everything.
Yeah.
It's not implausible.
I mean,
you don't have to,
uh,
you don't have to invoke miracles.
It's just,
it's something that happened,
but then somehow we,
I mean,
I don't understand why,
uh,
archeology is another one of these things.
It's in denial about this stuff.
Yeah.
Or,
well,
did you hear what they found about cheese?
They found that the more recent studies have shown that the,
uh,
the oldest,
the carbon dating that are getting back from these,
uh,
cheesemaking,
whatever they are,
pottery or whatever the fuck it is,
7,000 years,
you know,
they're making cheese 7,000 years ago.
That's how it is.
That,
I mean,
that is,
that's advanced stuff.
And when you add that to the,
the of the,
the need previous notion has LX 6,000 years ago,
like Sumac,
that was probably oldest thing we know.
Then they find,
go back to the topic,
right.
As they're uncovering that and they don't for sure.
That's at least 14,000,
14,000.
Right.
So I think it's entirely plausible.
It's not that far fetched to think that there may have been some,
okay.
Some contact with some extra terrestrials civilization.
I mean,
you find this myth.
No.
Well,
I mean,
everything that you're talking about necessarily,
I'm not really sure how you jumped from civilizations are older than we thought
to sexiness.
Other than that.
Yeah.
But they all have this,
this myth of [inaudible] and the Incas and the new world.
It's very culture,
uh,
of a superior being who puruse historically critical juncture and basically
civil license.
Isn't it possible that that superior being is some dude who grew up on the other
part of the world that had the mushrooms,
their whole culture evolves to a,
are radically higher level and then they get an boats and come over to these
eight white people.
They're still throwing sticks.
Yeah.
Something like that.
Shock my bag and my shows and go catch a cast and a couple of decades
work it out yourself.
Yeah.
They came back to the Incas slaughtering people know like,
okay,
you guys are doing it wrong.
Right,
right.
So you know,
I don't know.
This is why we need to admit time travel so we can actually go back and verify
it with just what the fuck was going on.
Somebody said something once,
that was one of the most I may may have been correct.
Wow.
I don't remember who it was,
but he said that one day the they're going to get to a point where computer
processing power is so incredible that you were going to be able to take you on
all of the data on all the variables of life and circumstances on this planet
and calculate those and go back in time based on what we have today and knowing
how fast cars are,
what it takes to burn gasoline,
but all of these massive,
insane amount of data and literally be able to extrapolate what what happened in
the past through some sort of a mathematical equation.
It's impossible for us to wrap our heads around now because we're just not there
yet,
but whatever it is establishing your from now 5,000 years to run,
they literally will be able to at least go back in time and information way.
Well,
this sounds,
this is similar to,
okay,
so you're going to say
it's the physics of your mortality or actually I was bragging to your formation.
It's
foundations like based on that idea,
except they use demographic to calculate what will happen.
Yeah.
I'm planning for our society,
right?
Based on these incredibly complex computer algorithms about here's the
demographics who see you count on next year's though social,
we can
predict what will happen,
what will happen,
but find this level of detail.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
frank ticklers work the physics of evil or chatting with Wifi.
No,
I've heard that.
I've heard the name of that book.
Yeah.
It's,
it's interesting.
I mean he had this idea that,
you know,
computing power,
like he says like Chris,
while computing power is exponentially increasing and that at some point it will
be possible to simulate heaven and that you know,
people,
it will be essentially possible too.
Uh,
well,
uh,
to enter a simulated world,
that is the,
the world beyond death.
That is the vision by the world's major religions.
This is,
you know,
when at the end of time we will in fact all be resurrected into this says
computer simulations of ourselves.
Are you familiar with this?
Most recent,
the idea of computer simulation theory,
but they have actually found this self repairing computer software.
We coho repairing mathematical code and a,
the equations of a,
a strength area
and stuff.
No,
this guy was with the Neil degrasse Tyson had this,
uh,
interview with this physicist that's trying to explain it,
but it was a type of self correcting computer code that they discovered in 1940
or was invented and created in 1940.
Let me pull this up because I don't want you this
[inaudible]
okay.